back to Simon though today he came out
to support Carrie Underwood at her
Hollywood Walk of Fame ceremony
yeah the Idol family they're very a
tight-knit little Bunch and an emotional
Carrie was definitely feeling the love
I've been so blessed in my life to have
so many people who have crab I'm crying
so many people who have believed in me
13 years after becoming an American Idol
Carrie super stardom is officially part
of Hollywood history proudly supporting
her today
hockey pro husband Mike Fisher and their
adorable three-year-old son Isaiah I
love you so much you're the best thing
we ever did the best thing the little
guy was sure loving the attention
hamming it up between his mom and dad
Carrie who covered her bump in a red
trench coat was also celebrated by
country music pal Brad Paisley and Simon
Cowell who admitted he partied a bit too
much at last night's AGT finale I'm
there apologized to Carrie first of all
I have never felt so hungover in my life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]